Billy Gardell probably knows that song
very well back here in the Rich Eisen -
well I mean I guess that's so old that's
how old that song is in the league
no video tapings proper air pressure and
the balls no mysterious calls six are
you sick to your stomach still upset
still from something I was in New York
with my family because I've been blessed
enough to be able to do stuff like that
at the Christmas holiday mm-hmm
had a beautiful trip with the family but
I figured I better be indoors for that
Pittsburgh New England game because I am
a Steelers fan and there's some emotion
involved this time of year more than
usual I figure it would be safe for me
to be locked indoors like the Wolfman in
case things want to rise they did and
I'm sure that you know I've been very
blessed my job so we get to stay in nice
hotels and I'm pretty sure that the
folks in the Upper East Side aren't used
to hearing that coming out of a hotel
room but you know what I paid my money
just like they did so they had to endure
that now I will say this about to call
rich I will say that the rules are the
rules and I will I will accept that but
anybody who's watched football knows
that was a catch
rules are the rules they called the rule
to the letter of T okay I think the rule
needs to be looked at
we'll get another swing at them in the
playoffs I hope so I don't know what to
do and I didn't want to ruin dinner for
everyone so before we went out to dinner
in New York I said it's my way you know
I got to take a walk so just went out
started walking the streets in New York
City - it sounds just like a lonely man
Billy you just add Billy Gardell myself
this is like a dick in this novel at
this point the word picture what are you
wearing Billy what am I got I got my
black overcoat on I got my Irish hat on
and I got a scarf on and I got my hands
in my pockets and I'm walking down a
very windy lightly dusted with snow
Street Fifth Avenue in New York
mumbling to myself because it's not safe
for me to talk to people yet when I turn
the corner on the fifth off and I'm
walking and I and I felt what I think
New Yorkers feel for Boston sports
franchises for the first time in my life
so at least I was in a safe place on the
corner about the game they just kind of
went yeah yeah we know we know yeah and
so there was a comfort in there and so
as I'm walking as every Steeler frame
does we try to figure out I work how
could it happen how could we possibly
get this to swing back to where we could
get them at home and you know because
you don't want to play them up in
Foxborough it's like going into the
Death Star but you don't get out you
know I mean it's it just blows up while
you're in there it's like Road one now
you're not going to you lazy Punk's
listen to the story I know I hear so
anyways yeah I'm walking and I think I
don't know what we got to do to beat
these guys even when it seems like we
beat them the luck just goes away I
don't know if somebody put a Golden
Horseshoe and Brady's kidney when he was
born or what it just it just I hope
things work out for the guy his life
seems very toys so you know what's more
I like to see some go right for the kid
I really would so I'm walking and I'm
just in that frustration of I what do we
have to do and so I look at the schedule
the possibilities now we got Houston and
Cleveland and I'm pretty sure we can
lock that down yep we're gonna get a bye
hopefully and and we'll get one at home
but I'm thinking action I get how can I
possibly get how can I possibly get
those Patriots to come back to
Pittsburgh for that AFC Championship if
that were to happen so I looked at their
schedule and they got Buffalo coming up
which I'm pretty sure I'm not even sure
they're gonna wake Brady up for that
same
they are at home I mean I'm I think you
know Belichick will probably let Gronk
rest and then for the last game of the
season he'll raise him on that table let
lightning hit them and they'll reanimate
[Applause]
yes and as I stood there looking at the
schedule I looked up and there I was at
st. Patrick's Cathedral st. Patrick's I
thought my goodness this can't be an
accident
so I did something I went into st. Pat's
and I thought I I can't think of anyone
else to involve so that we can beat the
Patriots and get them at home so I went
to st. Patrick's and I went to the front
of the line and I lit a candle and I
said please God I know you got a lot on
your plate
we got an insane government we got
people lying to each other we don't know
how to talk to you tell you Martin I
want compassion for everyone but Lord I
want to put it one extra one on the list
this year
give me a snowstorm the last game of the
season as a New England comes into play
the New York Football just as I lit the
candle rich as a Steeler fan and
everyone else who's sick of this team
torturing them I said very merry quietly
under my breath I said Jay e.t.s Jets
Jets Jets and I walked out and the rest
is up to the universe my friend okay put
me at peace and I'm hoping for a
Christmas miracle and I went out to
dinner with my family
okay well Billy that's a very compelling
tale may I give you my reaction to it
Billy Gardell okay I have been praying
to I guess my own god right being a Jew
right about this very subject for damn
near five decades
[Laughter]
my prayers have been answered yet to
date unless unless you know there's
something within Christian Hackenberg I
don't see yet or Carol Bryan had
something that happened to him that I
didn't see or it hasn't happened so god
bless literally Billy well listen man if
the football gods want to deal some
justice they will that day but I am
going to I got to hold on to something
to try to get them back on my home field
bridge how about this Billy I'll give
you two more - yesterday on the show I
gave three scenarios the bills could
play the game of their lives I know you
mentioned I missed that boat I went down
to the dock I had my ticket the boat
went right by okay
the Chiefs the Chiefs win their first
wild card game and the Chiefs team that
won in week one in Foxborough shows up
and that Saturday or Sunday of January
mid-january and takes care of business
we all know how well it works out if you
beat them okay you just get punished the
next game thirty five to three and you
don't know what happened all right
here's the third one
John Harbaugh and the Ravens who have
done it before in the building yeah and
they've had horrible catch moments of
their own in that building when they
thought they had it won right he strolls
in and the second or Saturday or Sunday
or the month that takes care of business
I agree with you on that one there's a
light chance on that okay I would send
also a warning to every AFC team do not
take Jacksonville lightly this team that
that defense looks as real as it gets
and we all know what wins at the end of
the year except if you're playing the
Patriots then you got a score 35 and
have about 52 minutes of possession you
might get out of there with a win Billy
Gardell I love you happy holidays merry
Christmas to you happy Holidays to you
and your lovely family you too even to
that much
gloating behind it with him happy
holidays and happy holidays Billy god
bless all these guys man and let's go
Jets thanks Billy that's at Billy
Gardell on Twitter for more Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app